[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
this represents leadership at the local
level and partnership folks in Glenn
County Sacramento County the San Joaquin
Stanislaus Fresno Santa Barbara San
Bernardino Riverside we expect actions
to be taken today and yesterday la led
Kings County of insurace Solano and we
talked about Imperial County and how
they moved their credit in partnership
the spirit of partnership to meet this
moment and do more so that we can all do
better in mitigating the transmission
the spread of this disease so that
represents the vast majority the 19
counties were working with the other
counties and we made this clear again in
the spirit of partnership that we don't
want to do things to you but with you
but we reserve the right to move forward
this mandate if we don't see action of
the local level to monstre Blee just in
24 hours you've seen local level action
along the lines of what we are hoping
for and we expect all 19 to come into
compliance and again if not that hand
will be forced in the spirit that
requires this moment and and again we're
confident we're gonna see progress by
the way I want to also just acknowledge
the incredible progress we've seen as it
relates to Orange County's move and the
work local beaches and Huntington Beach
and some other Beach communities to
their credit their local elected
officials local health officers are
moving forward their own local decisions
that go beyond just closing parking lots
to help decompress their beaches over
the fourth of July weekend we want to
applaud that on acknowledge that and
also just thank again the leadership in
LA and Ventura County that really led
with that local framework looking again
specifically into this holiday weekend
with the kind of concern that many of us
have about people gathering mixing
outside of their household not
practicing physical distance he not
wearing face masks in the prospect than
in a week or two two to three weeks
we'll see those numbers spike yet again
I want to just encourage people as
always to do the right thing and we
expect the vast majority its
demonstrable on the
of the accidents you've seen from those
counties on that previous slide but we
want to courage as individuals and
business leaders to do the right thing
yesterday I announced that we were going
to send out notifications from our what
we call Occupational Safety and Health
aboard OSHA as it's commonly referred to
we put out over 350,000 letters that we
sent out yesterday specifically laying
out expectations in terms of good
business behaviors to protect not only
customers but to protect workers in
those businesses we also put out other
public health information and mandates
that we also will follow up through this
enforcement action that we highlighted
yesterday six regions of the state teams
of anywhere from seven state agencies to
as many as ten state agencies that will
be going out in the spirit of
collaboration spirit of Education spirit
of cooperation and not a punitive frame
first but an encouragement frame first
to help enforce all of these efforts
again because the seriousness if we take
a right to related to the recent spread
an increase in cases of kovat 19 let's
talk about that increase in spread in
the last 24 hour according period we saw
4050 six cases that were identified as
positive to begin the month of July we
have seen over the course of the last 14
days our positivity rate now rise to six
point three percent again it started
40.8% when we did the first 14 day where
all we saw a significant decline in the
positivity rate unfortunately we're
starting to see an increase in the
positivity rate not only over a 14 day
period but over the last seven days it
has been six point nine percent looking
though at the 14 day period I want to
show you that trend line that's why we
have the mask mandate this is why we're
doing the PSAs this is why we're
encouraging you to take individual
responsibility more social
sponsibility to protect your family or
friends in the broader community but the
slide you see represented here that
increase in that orange line represents
a 37% increase in the positivity rate
just over a two-week period again now
over 14 day period six point three
percent the number of hospitalizations
I've said this many occasions I'll
repeat it again today hospitalizations
as you see positivity rates go up total
number of cases that are identified as
positive we're going to see a trend line
of increase in hospitalization as a
legging indicator we've now had a 56
percent increase in hospitalizations
over the two-week reporting period 56
percent just over a two week reporting
period again reinforcing the importance
of these local actions and reinforcing
the importance of your personal
responsibility your actions on behalf of
yourself your families over the course
of this holiday weekend total number of
hospitalizations represents five
thousand three hundred and fifty five
patients in a hospital system that has
capacity for 73 thousand eight hundred
and sixty-seven so again that represents
about seven percent of the total
population of our current hospital
system beds the total number of people
patients admitted overall is 46 thousand
and thirty five that's represented in
that 62 percent number
this again is a slide if you've been
watching tuning in you're very familiar
with but that coded patient population
still represents about seven percent six
seven percent has been rather consistent
over the course last number of days I'm
moving in to last week I see use I see
use or up some forty nine percent in the
last two weeks you could see not
surprisingly as you see trend line
increase on positivity rates trend line
increases on hospital rates and
variability will see trend lines
increasing on ICU admissions ICU
missions represent on this pie chart
you'll see that subset of the ten
thousand seven hundred and eighty eight
total ICU beds 1676 are filled with ICU
kovat positive patients we still have
capacity in our ICU system again least
this is capacity in the aggregate and
I'll remind everybody none of us live in
the aggregate we live in communities
large and small different Hospital
resources different capacity resources
but this in the aggregate represents our
total capacity including the total
number of ventilators in the states
still in excess of 11,000 of 400-plus
ventilators that we have within the
hospital system and in our cash here at
the office emergency service what we
refer to as m7 as relates to this fourth
of July weekend again we have the
mandatory closures as it relates to
certain activities within sectors within
businesses indoor activities is where
we're trying to push outdoors indoor
dining we want to push this outdoor
dining I want to get as many of those
activities where you're mixing or can
come into contact with people you
haven't been with in your household
may come into contact and mix with them
increasing the likely to the spread of
this virus we're trying to mitigate that
and this fourth of July weekend is one
of the most social weekends in our lives
and this is perhaps my last formal
opportunity as we move into that weekend
many of you will move in tomorrow on
Friday not just a formerly over Saturday
and Sunday I wanted to remind you that
many cities have already canceled their
firework shows many cities have already
adopted their own local guidelines
saying we'll continue to do our
fireworks but we encourage you to stay
in your cars or stay home and just enjoy
them from afar again in those 19
counties that we are working very
closely with we want to see those
fireworks shows diminished or eliminated
accordingly we want to remind you that
we don't want to see you a bunch of
strangers without being physically
distanced and without wearing
coverings over the weekend it's the
extent you can that's why we say avoid
crowds and avoid going to large parades
outside of your household again this is
common sense and I don't mean to be
patronizing or paternalistic about all
of this
I'm just working with local health
officials dealing with the data the
science on trying to mitigate as we were
so successful mitigating the spread of
this disease by by tempering that growth
of the curve in the beginning we need to
do that again we will do that again and
it's really gonna be up to each and
every one of you to see how quickly oh
we can do that and that's why this
weekend is so important we put out more
formal fourth of July weekend guidelines
that are up on the kovat 19 dot ca.gov
website but encourage you to follow them
take seriously this weekend take
seriously this moment that we're living
in a moment it's not permanent a moment
that we'll get through together but we
have to continue to fight this disease
do more and do better accordingly no
important way you could do that and
wearing a mask wearing a face covering
and I want to just encourage all of you
and the spirit that brings us this PSA
that brings this new media campaign to
the forefront to do what you can to
protect yourself to protect others and
send a message that recognizes that
we're not out of this pandemic we're
still in the first wave and we have a
lot of work to do to mitigate the spread
to make sure that our hospital system is
ready to receive people outside of an
emergency for a Kovan related cause to
make sure I see use accordingly
are free from kovat patients in order to
do that there's nothing more important
impactful no greater imperative than
wearing a face covering when you're out
of your home you're out and about in the
community so again wishing all of you a
happy 4th of July weekend with all of
these criteria and conditions and
modifications in mind
and as always we are here to answer any
questions
I know governor thank you very much for
taking our questions again with all due
respect yesterday you talked about the
enforcement thing mostly on businesses
you're putting a lot of the
responsibility a lot of the onus a lot
of the consequences on businesses when
there have been many instances of people
ignoring the orders of the businesses in
ordering face masks or physical
distancing so what is the harm in asking
law enforcement agencies across the
state to enforce the and in the LA
County Sheriff's Department in the West
Hollywood area they're going to issue
tickets 300 bucks I think for the first
offense so why not make that a mandate
that if I was walking down the street
would open container I'd be stopped and
given a ticket why not if I'm walking in
a crowd without a mask I don't get a
ticket I guess I I don't understand why
all of the consequence and onus is on
the businesses not the individual yeah
forgive me if you were led to that
opinion yesterday I went to great
lengths and this is an opportunity I'm
grateful for the opportunity and the
question to prompt the opportunity
repeat some of the things I said we
began by talking about a fiscal
contingency that we put into place with
the California Legislature some two and
a half billion dollars in our budget is
contingent upon counties enforcing the
orders that their health officers have
put forward by definition that's an
enforcement mandate that goes far and
wide beyond just the issue of
enforcement for businesses I highlighted
businesses because as a businessperson
myself I think businesses have a role
and responsibility to protect their
workers as well as their customers and
that's why we have the frame of
engagement not a punitive frame but a
frame of education and engagement to
work through conditions we've got these
teams in six different regions in this
state they're targeting enforcement
based upon abuse again not to try to be
punitive but people have turned their
back or been particularly more
problematic in the past
by definition the contingency on the two
and a half billion dollars related to
health officers and mandates transcends
again just the business sector and that
includes masks and includes a
cross-section of roles and
responsibilities so we look at
regulatory we look at codes we look at
encouragement we look at education
that's the purpose of today's
presentation is an education campaign
and we look to local elected officials
local county officials local sheriff's
local police officers and the like to do
justice but as you know a lot of local
enforcement is also targeted for people
walking for example in your example
walking with alcohol as they shouldn't
be or people that are abusing you know
not using the intersection or jaywalking
you tend to educate first and if you're
not successful and you still have
problems then you enforce more formally
you could put out warning citations you
could put out educational material and
eventually if you're not seeing
behavioral change you're absolutely
right and then we think citations are
warranted where there's abuse so thank
you for the opportunity to reinforce
what I said yesterday and to and clarify
any ambiguity of concerns reflected in
your question Thank You governor that
that stat of I see you use is very
concerning I'm wondering if there will
be any difference in the state's
approach to may be dealing with
protesters or large groups of people
that are out on the street and also you
talk about family barbecues and the
concern about people gathering is there
anything you can do as a state to
discourage that or regulate that in any
way or that sort of just up to everybody
to do on their own yeah I'd say it's all
of this you know there are laws on the
books that if we tried to enforce at
scale we never could that transcendence
predate Cove in nineteen the 40 million
people want to turn their back on civil
society and abuse the rules laws and
regulations on a consistent basis at
scale
then society begins to erode accordingly
the health of a community begins to be
diminished and so look we have a health
crisis in this nation we are not out of
this crisis we're still in the first
wave of this crisis it requires some
level of personal responsibility and so
what we're doing is educating people
we're encouraging people we're not just
doing it at a press conference at noon
with one individual a governor we're
trying to do that and you saw some of
the material we put out and very
culturally competent way with trusted
messengers with celebrities we're trying
to reach a younger cohort not just an
older cohort or traditional broadcast at
the same time going on to tick-tock and
going on to some of these social media
platforms getting some well-known
celebrities influencers to do the same
to encourage people to do the right
thing and that's what I'm asking
couraging people to use their common
sense to protect themselves if for
nothing else
consider yourself but if you don't
consider yourself you feel like you're
immune from prospects of having any
health risk
I consider others consider that video we
put out of that person was holding on
for her dear life that could be your
mother
it could be your grand mother it could
be someone you deeply loved it also
could be a stranger that you walked by
in passing where you were asymptomatic
or pre-symptomatic and you didn't
experience any ill or didn't feel any
experiencing any symptoms of feeling ill
and you may have spread that disease to
someone and never known that three weeks
later that person may be on an ICU no
one wants to do that and so again I I'm
just encouraging same time we're
stepping up we've been clear based on
the previous question we're stepping up
our enforcement not just the businesses
but across the spectrum and encouraging
people to do more and do better look as
it relates to the ICU is you're
absolutely right
I see use our point of real concern goes
back to the ventilator questions it goes
back to our capacity well beyond just
Koba 19 to deal with the needs of people
in acute medical conditions and so
that is that's a number we have closely
monitor 49% 49% increase in the last two
weeks seventy-three human beings lost
their lives in the last 24 hours
because of this disease 110 lost their
lives and the reporting period that I
provided you yesterday don't think for a
second we were out of the woods as dr.
Ghali reminds me we're on the second or
third inning of this nine inning game by
no stretch are we out of the woods but
we can influence we can mitigate the
spread we can again bend this curve we
can lower the ICU rates we can lower the
hospitalization rates we can lower the
positivity rights you we collectively
society becomes out we behave in the
collective individual acts smart
thoughtful not on about yourself but
about others will mitigate the spread
hey governor I wanted to ask about how
the new restrictions that you announced
yesterday change the reopening strategy
going forward are there any lessons from
what didn't work about the approach so
far that going to inform any changes to
how those counties reopen at the end of
these three weeks or however long it is
before did you feel they're stable
enough to start reopening businesses
again how have you developed a different
strategy around that I appreciate that
question good question and I hope you'll
see represented in today's action an
example of a response to your question
more targeted education I think the most
important thing we've learned over the
course last number of months even in the
conversations that we have the questions
in the response through dozens and
dozens of these opportunities that we
share together in a very public way is
so often the conversation the questions
we're about when
not how we need to have deeper
conversation about how to safely reopen
and that's what this public education
campaign is all about and that's what
you're going to hear from me more and
more and more and so directly in
response to your question let us begin
anew to focus on the guidelines with
more intensity more specificity and let
us do more to focus on how we can safely
reopen we can safely reopen but we have
to change we have to modify and we have
to adapt different set of expectations
and behaviors and if we can't socially
enforce them through encouragement and
education we'll have to lean in a little
bit more to further the cause of
mitigating the spread hi governor thanks
for taking this question given the
alarming number that you just reported
what do you say to critics who suggest
that your BSA's may be great but you can
free your office to get tougher on
enforcement I know you've been asked
this but I mean there are people I think
why aren't you and just imposing fines
on those who don't abide by the
statewide mass mandate when you've got
cities doing it why are you going there
and then there's a local officials
planning events to fret and Fresno come
they'd say the Fresno Fair is going on
despite the fact that they're expecting
six hundred thousand people to show up
there possibly just say a fall surge
occurs again are you going to take
action against that and take some kind
of measure to stop those kind of events
forcibly what's your answer Thank You
Carla for the question it's an
opportunity again to reinforce response
I had a few questions prior opportunity
to reinforce what we said yesterday and
thank you for that opportunity as well
to reinforce what we were previewing
over the course of a number of weeks
here is the substantive answer to your
question we have made contingent two and
a half billion dollars to an F billion
dollars of resources we refer to as
cares AK dollars and Realignment dollars
to counties that are unwilling to
enforce their local health officers
mandates we have conditioned those
dollars on a set of expectation that we
will have more robust funding
unfortunately I couldn't do that on my
own
I couldn't just sign an executive order
to make contingent contributions to
counties I needed the consent and
concurrence from the California
Legislature let me thank the California
Legislature I was able to sign a budget
just on Monday that afforded us the
opportunity with the language in what we
refer to as the trailer bill that allows
contingent expectation of performance
under the health ordinances that
substantively goes to your question of
enforcing the health ordinance and the
mandates that we are providing yesterday
announced that we have now sent out
teams these teams are teams that
systemic lis are going to integrate in
very very prescriptive ways
organizations and entities that are
well-known like the alcohol beverage
control with organizations that are less
well-known like the BB C not the ABC
which is the bar the board of barbers
and cosmetologists working with CHP
working with the Department of Labor
working with different state agencies
Consumer Affairs and others in a
cross-sectoral strategy to target in six
regions in the state of California the
enforcement the state of California and
you know this well state of California
jurisdictionally is constructed not top
down but bottom up state of California
has over a thousand school districts
independently elected school boards
it has enforcement mechanisms that exist
and reside even within the school system
many of those school boards have hired
their own police departments which is a
point of consternation critique and
concern many of the enforcement
mechanisms that reside within cities
reside within city councils
directly with city administrators and
mayor's county level county boards of
Supervisors fund primarily the County
Sheriff's all of these jurisdictions
have a role in responsibility to play on
the enforcement if we don't see those
roles being advanced if we don't see the
level of enforcement that I can hear in
your voice you're encouraging or you are
described based upon those have inquired
to you
that's precisely why we put up two and a
half billion dollars of contingent money
it's precisely why we have these teams
already assembled in six key regions in
this state it's precisely why we'll
continue because we have been enforcing
at the alcohol beverage code we have
been enforcing for months at BBC will
continue to build on that enforcement
frame and it's exactly why I began
forgive me for belaboring this it's
exactly why I began with that slide
showing counties including Fresno that
presumably is acting today based upon
the input they provided us this morning
to advance the spirit and the letter of
the mandate that we announced yesterday
that should also mitigate the concern
that you referenced about their
particular activities hi governor thank
you for taking my questions
I'm calling down here from Orange County
and just wanted to know what will be
done about Orange County's past
disregard for enforcing mask orders step
with the sheriff it said about taking
more educational approach when we're
going into the fourth of July weekend
and yeah I mean and whether or not you
think that that fiscal contingency
strategy will be enough for a county
like ours that has shown such disregard
for it well I certainly hope and expect
it well I had a really robust
conversation with organization that you
know well others may not called SESAC
it's basically the organization
representing 58 counties in the state of
California they have an outstanding
leader Graham who and in a wonderful
president of their organization
supervisor Bartlett from Orange County
she was magnificent in the phone call
yesterday in terms of her understanding
of this moment her desire to meet it
[ __ ] representative responsibilities as
a supervisor working through SESAC as
the current president of SESAC and its
director Graham to make sure that we are
working together and that we're I to I
in terms of how the contingency plan may
work she expressed understandably
concern at a lot of counties by the
magnitude of the money because two and a
half million dollars is a significant
amount of money for counties that are
struggling right now particularly with
related costs associated with Kovan 19
and revenue declines as a consequence of
kovat 19 so we have their attention I
assure you and let me just say not only
is it demonstrable in that conversation
we had yesterday but it's also I think
demonstrable in Orange County today that
looks as if they are moving it's
interesting we were in the midst of a
dispute a bit around our respective
jurisdictions and my authority as
governor to oppose a mandate to mitigate
some of the crowds on the beaches in
Orange County there was a lot of
pushback as you know well coming from
the county now Huntington Beach Newport
and Laguna and others folks in the
county are moving forward on their own
and I'm very grateful for that so I
think it's an example the fact in some
ways we're turning the page and other
respects we may not be and so we'll
continue to engage them but I just want
to thank the leadership down there and I
want to thank all the county
representatives that I know are working
hard to keep their community safe and
are really engaging in the spirit of
cooperation that is required at this
moment hi governor and your ramped up
restrictions that you announced
yesterday for the 19 counties I mean
notably not on the list were places like
churches and gyms and fitness centers
day camps even government bodies that
are still meeting in some of these
really highly impact
Bounty's why is that well as I stated
multiple occasions yesterday when I had
the one-on-one conversations with the
list were like churches attended so I
had a little feedback there I had an
opportunity to talk to many of you
one-on-one in interviews yesterday that
question was posed on multiple occasions
I forgive me if I may come across a
repeating myself from some of you that
directly asked we specifically put out
number of things happen yesterday we
specifically put out new guidelines for
gyms yesterday and encourage you to take
a look under the guidelines sections of
Cova in 19 ca.gov to learn more about
those guidelines for gyms we also put
out new guidelines for places of worship
which is also available in the covin 19
ca.gov websites so specifically we
updated the guidelines yesterday in that
space I referenced yesterday and in
those interviews that we had with many
of you that as it relates to casinos in
the state we are having
government-to-government conversations
with sovereigns the tribal nations
reside within the state of California
respecting their sovereignty and
respecting the incredible partnership we
have had over the course of many many
years but also in the beginning of this
pandemic where they moved and worked
with their county health officers or at
least with their their Koch partners in
the counties that they operate in to
advance the stay at home order and many
have been models as it relates to how to
effectively and safely reopen so we're
working with them as well I made it
clear yesterday and I'll make it clear
today we have a lot of work we're doing
not only with those 19 counties but a
number of other counties that we think
certainly may come on on the monitoring
list as well as other sectors of our
economy so we want to be targeted
it'll be targeted to hotspots we want to
be targeted based upon what we're
hearing from health officials and
counties as it relates to their concerns
around spread and we want to
work as we have sectorally with industry
leaders to put out guidelines and update
them and I can assure you you'll be
among the first to know as soon as we
make any additional updates we will make
them public and we'll continue to
monitor the situation and be flexible in
our decision-making on a daily basis
this disease doesn't take weekends off
nor do we in terms of updating our
health advice and counsel hi doesn'r I
know yesterday and correct me if I'm
wrong but I think you said that chp was
involved in the strike force on
enforcement with the same guidelines but
I'm looking at the HP's permit calendar
for the 4th of July the same day I know
your administration is kind of urging
everyone to not gather what people they
don't know and I'm seeing that there's a
300 person protest two weddings
another demonstration all with you know
dozens of people and the 300 person
process I just I want to know what your
how you address what some might perceive
as mixed messaging here yeah I don't
have the benefit of the details of the
permits that they are looking at forgive
me for not having that I pride myself on
having a lot of information but not all
the permits that have gone in front of
the state agency that said I do have
something perhaps more valuable and
that's markula du chí the head of the
office of emergency services here that
works for the CHP hand-in-glove is
leading our strike force efforts and
maybe you could talk more broadly to
spirit the question you just posed them
Thank You governor so there are you know
CHP has gotten permitting requests for
protest and obviously you know we have
been working to try to provide the
opportunity for peaceful protest to take
place CHP is evaluating those permits
now to see about how that can be done
safely taking into account the
governor's orders and directives that we
want for appropriate social distancing
and limiting of
to come together while still protecting
people's rights to assemble for for
peaceful protest so as you know we've
had the protest that went on through the
course of a couple weeks ago and and so
we're trying to continually balance that
with safety and security and and the
ability to continue to allow for people
to exercise their their civil rights
thank you
next question
[Music]
hi governor not to be badly limping
horse here but I want to get back to
enforcement question I feared that you
might perfectly okay just I've heard
from people who say they don't
understand why they're being told you
can't go see grandpa this weekend you
can't be Uncle Joe you can't have a
barbecue with your neighbors but then
they turn on the TV and they see
hundreds or thousands of people
protesting and can you explain you know
basically that a selective enforcement
preferential treatment giving based on
political persuasion can you explain for
people why they should listen to these
messages when they do see that happening
and no one getting tickets don't even
being told to enforce the masks for
social distancing yeah if they care
about their grandfather their uncle
their aunt that's why they should listen
I I'm not look we're not going to
everybody's backyard and enforcing you
know that and they know that we're just
encouraging people to be safe to be
thoughtful about themselves and others
just because I honestly I I maybe was
unique in my household but I don't think
it was I think it's universally taught
just because someone else is doing it
doesn't mean you should I remember my
mother my dad saying that and probably
2,000 occasions just because someone
else is doing it doesn't mean you should
people know what the right thing to do
is I encourage them to do the right
thing and people also understand that we
have a constitution we have the right of
free speech and we are all dealing
with a moment in our nation's history
that is profound and pronounced you know
that as well and I think many of those
individuals are you referring to in that
hypothetical or the literal example
you're proposing also understand that
and I I recognize the dichotomy and to
the extent the dialectic between those
examples and all I can offer is this
consideration I do what you think is
best not only for you but for the health
of those you love look at the
epidemiology look at the spread of this
virus over the last few weeks look at
the fact that our hospitalization rate
has gone up 56 percent in just two weeks
consider the fact that I see yous have
gone up 49 percent in the last few weeks
consider that when you go about coming
together perhaps with members of your
family or strangers or neighbors you
haven't been with in some time over the
course of the weekend and just consider
one of those stats maybe you and if you
think this isn't it won't impact you
because it hasn't impacted you I hope to
disabuse you of that based upon not only
the 73 lives that were lost in the last
24 hours 110 the previous 24 hours or
the fact that we are now experiencing
unprecedented rates of growth Cobin 19 I
just I hope you'll be safe not because
we have the tools or capacity to enforce
40 million individuals and their
decisions of behavior but because as a
community we're capable of doing more to
meet this moment and to mitigate the
spread and so I am calling on the better
angels and for people to use their
common sense and do what they can to to
keep themselves safe keep their loved
ones safe and the extent that we have
agencies up and down the state doing
enforcement doing the kind of outreach
and education well we are now doing that
at a record scale that we've never done
in the past and we're just hoping that
we'll see some
modification of behavior that may have
happened on the natural and the default
as we not put out all this guidance all
these recommendations and these public
service announcements so look thank you
all for staying on messages reporters in
terms of the questions and thank you all
to members of the public those of you
that have given me the privilege of your
time thank you for extending it yet
again I'm grateful to you and I just
encourage everybody I haven't said it
enough I'll say it one final time before
we enter in to this holiday weekend
happy fourth of July weekend and wear a
mask take care everybody
you